GOING UP AND UP EACH MONTH.
>> KEEP UP THE GREAT REPORTING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
GRIFF: FOR MORE WE’RE JOINED BY
FORMER ACTING DHS SECRETARY AND
HERITAGE FOUNDATION VISITING
FELLOW CHAD WOLF.
MR. SECRETARY, THANK YOU FOR
TAKING TIME ON A SATURDAY.
I WANT TO -- YOU JUST HEARD BILL
MELUGIN’S REPORT ABOUT THE
CRIMINALS BEING APPREHENDED.
THE CHIEF IN THE DEL RIO SECTOR
TWEETED YESTERDAY THAT THERE ARE
438 CRIMINAL MIGRANTS THAT
THEY’VE APPREHENDED JUST IN THAT
SECTOR IN DEL RIO ALONE OF WHICH
77 ARE SEX OFFENDERS, 7
CONVICTED MURDERERS.
THAT’S JUST ONE IS SECTOR.
MR. SECRETARY, HOW CONCERNED ARE
YOU THAT WITH THESE OVERWHELMING
NUMBERS WE HAVEN’T SEEN IN TWO
DECADES IS LETTING IN AN UNKNOWN
AMOUNT OF CRIMINALS?
>> WELL, IT’S ABSOLUTELY A
CONCERN.
WE HAVE A HUMANITARIAN CRISIS
GOING ON AT THAT BORDER, BUT
WITHIN THAT IS ALSO A SECURITY
CRISIS.
SO MORE AND MORE THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT IS NOT ON THE LINE
DOING THEIR NATIONAL SECURITY
MISSION AND THEY’RE IN BORDER
PATROL STATIONS CARING FOR THESE
MIGRANTS, THESE FAMILY UNITS AND
THESE MINORS, THE LESS AGENTS
THAT WE HAVE ON THE LINE LOOKING
FOR THESE CRIMINALS AND STOPPING
THAT ILLEGAL FLOW.
SO THERE’S CERTAINLY A SECURITY
ACCOUNT ASPECT HERE THAT’S VERY,
VERY CONCERNING.
WE KNOW FROM EXPERIENCE GOING
BACK TO 2019 AND EVEN EARLIER,
WE KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE A LARGE
NUMBER OF INDIVIDUALS COMING TO
THE BORDER EVERY SINGLE DAY AND
NIGHT, WE KNOW THAT BAD PEOPLE
TRY TO HIDE THEMSELVES WITHIN
THAT FLOW.
SO I’M GLAD TO HEAR THAT BORDER
PATROL IS ABLE TO IDENTIFY SOME
OF THESE FOLKS, BUT THERE’S A
LARGE NUMBER OF FOLKS EVERY
SINGLE DAY, OVER A THOUSAND,
CLOSER TO TWO THOUSAND, THAT ARE
WHAT WE CALL GOT-AWAYS.
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE
NEVER ENCOUNTERED BY BORDER
PATROL.
SO THAT’S WHAT CONCERNS ME,
BECAUSE YOU DON’T KNOW IF THOSE
ARE FAMILY UNITS, MS-13 MEMBERS,
IF THEY’RE TERRORISTS AND
OTHERS.
SO THERE’S CERTAINLY A SECURITY
ASPECT TO THAT BORDER THAT IS
CERTAINLY A CONCERN DURING THIS
HUMANITARIAN CRISIS.
GRIFF: WELL, SURE IT IS.
AND AS OUR VIEWERS ARE LOOKING,
THAT’S OUR DRONE FOOTAGE IN THE
RGV SECTOR, AND THEY GO RIGHT
THROUGH THAT WALL OPENING, AND
THEY GO TO THE FARM TO MARKET
ROAD OVER TO HIGHWAY 2, STRAIGHT
UP NORTH AND ALL OVER THE
COUNTRY.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE GOT-AWAYS,
LET’S TALK ABOUT THE NUMBER
RELEASED.
WE’RE NOW HEARING MORE THAN
61,000 MIGRANTS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED INTO THE UNITED STATES
SINCE FEBRUARY COMPARED TO 364
IN THE PRESIDENT TRUMP’S LAST
YEAR.
THAT IS A STARTLING NUMBER.
YOUR REACTION.
>> IT ABSOLUTELY IS A STARTLING
NUMBER, AND IT’S A DIRECT RESULT
OF THE POLICIES THAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT IN PLACE
OVER THE LAST FOUR MONTHS.
IF YOU’RE A MINOR, YOU GOING TO
GET RELEASED INTO THE UNITED
STATES.
IF YOU’RE A FAMILY UNIT, YOU ARE
LIKELY GOING TO BE RELEASED INTO
THE UNITED STATES.
SO WHAT DOES THAT DO?
THAT INCENTIVIZES YOU TO GRAB A
CHILD AND TRY TO CLAIM ACROSS
THAT BORDER AND CLAIM YOU’RE A
FAMILY UNIT BECAUSE YOU KNOW YOU
WILL BE RELEASED INTO THE
INTERIOR OF THE UNITED STATES,
AND THAT’S YOUR GOAL AT THE END
OF THE DAY.
AND THAT’S WHAT THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS FACILITATING.
AND ONCE YOU GET HERE, YOU WILL
NOT BE REMOVED BECAUSE AGAIN,
THIS ADMINISTRATION HAS PUT THE
HANDCUFFS OF I.C.E. AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENTS.
THEY CANNOT REMOVE ILLEGALS
UNLESS YOU’RE A SERIOUS
AGGRAVATED FELON OR YOU’RE A
TERRORIST --
GRIFF: EXACTLY.
AND WE’VE ONLY GOT ABOUT A
MINUTE LEFT, MR. SECRETARY, BUT
WE HAVE SEEN, OF COURSE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN REJECTING THE
ABOLISH I.C.E. CALLS EARLY ON
POLITICALLY, BUT IT SEEMS THAT
MANY OF THE THINGS FROM THE
NUMBER OF DEPORTATIONS DOWN 60%
TO THE REALLY TAKING AWAY
ENFORCEMENT TOOLS FOR I.C.E.
THAT THEY’VE DONE JUST THAT,
ABOLISH THEM.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK THE ADMINISTRATION’S
JUST PAYING LIP SERVICE TO WE’RE
NOT GOING TO ABOLISH I.C.E.
EVERYTHING THAT THEY HAVE DONE,
THE POLICIES THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE, THEY’RE NOW GOING BACK ON
PRIVATE DETENTION FACILITIES, SO
THEY’RE TRYING TO REREDUCE THE
NUMBER OF FACILITIES OUT THERE.
EVERY SINGLE POLICY THAT THEY
HAVE DONE IS TO TEAR DOWN
I.C.E.’S ABILITY TO DO THEIR JOB
AT THE END OF THE DAY.
SO INSTEAD OF CONGRESS CHANGING
THE LAW, WHICH THEY WON’T DO
BECAUSE THEY DON’T HAVE A
CONSENSUS, THIS ADMINISTRATION
IS TRYING TO DO IT THROUGH
EXECUTIVE ORDER AND THROUGH
POLICY.
IT’S WRONG, IT’S DANGEROUS, AND
WE’RE NOT PROTECTING OUR
COMMUNITIES LIKE WE SHOULD.